we got to start an anti hype house in
cell house okay we build an anti hive
house we dance battle oh oh
we take 16 in sales dude and we make
them we make themselves we make them
sell a bit I mean yeah no no that's not
the right word we take 16 in sales and
we make them attractive okay we turn
them in sales have the groundwork for
the e boy look mm-hmm already they're
pale yeah their hair is greasy yeah they
just need a few piercings split it down
the middle split it down the middle
gavel piercing double piercings and
they're available chains yeah and it's
there look at it it's already there yeah
dude yeah [ __ ] I'm in I it would just
suck to be like an just like an average
looking teen right now when you oh yeah
cause it's like you're not like like you
want tick-tock that should they put on
the fruit for you page all you see is
dudes with just insane jawline yeah yeah
and and beautiful girls like that's all
it is yeah oh yeah that's it they don't
put one average looking person on the
[ __ ] any any time now let me let me go
is what ya take talk with the file let
me get some
average dancing [ __ ] kids kids were
just a little off yeah just a little
behind the tempo yeah I want to see some
like decent choreography yeah yeah yeah
yeah do your thing yeah do your thing
they have the standard is like all the
way up here
we gotta make you know the inverse we
got a house for the regular people you
gotta make the regular house so what was
your inspiration in creating the Intel
ugh I want to represent for all my guys
that's on the computer that's online
that you know don't really be talking to
girls like that yeah I want to put down
for my guys yeah you know I'm trying to
get them out trying to get them out
oh we got yeah we got a look what's the
what's the anti hype house what's the
what's another there's hype and then
there's the dry house know there's
Hydrox join us 12 Mormons yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah can't drink in that [ __ ]
everyone's just it's pent-up sexual
frustration yeah they can't and they can
only do certain dances because it can't
be too sex that's kind of just a Mormon
bachelor or whatever they're Provost or
whatever now they're not that [ __ ] up
man this night we get started on that
okay now that's just that's just them
Riven The Bachelor yeah okay they're the
12 of them in the house will not compete
yeah to be with each other yeah yeah hmm
there's no I see yeah and if they're
yeah or like make them Amish or some
[ __ ]
there it is so they can't like Mennonite
yeah Mennonite yes so they get like
nothing nothing can be sexual but
they're still like doing these dances
yeah better all of them are so hyper
sexualized the answers right like this
[ __ ] yeah you see that one yeah what the
[ __ ] are you doing what is that [ __ ] do
that to someone in public that's like
that's like sexual harassment just going
after someone going
that's sexual harassment why some
clothes kid dancing in LAX and he was
like LOL the dude behind me was not
feeling it he and the kid is dancing and
the dude is like in like a car like he's
trying to drive by him and he can't I
saw that one you know yeah yeah and then
he's the dude in the car is like looking
at other people and they're like latin
it's crazy that the kid thinks that
they're the issue yeah yeah
sorry I just gotta do a little dance gif
there's a [ __ ] airport
wow dude clearly you're not feeling it
yeah I'm not feeling not being able to
do my [ __ ] job
why wouldn't I not feel that that's why
we have to make the inverse hype how
scuzz we have to promote that there are
regular people out there we should do
this man yeah we're gonna we're just
gonna get like a three-bedroom in
Burbank yeah this sounds like a porn oh
maybe not Burbank we're never gonna get
a house we're just gonna get like we're
just gonna rent like called the but the
[ __ ] hype apartment the cool bungalow
now that sounds dope yeah okay all right
we're just gonna [ __ ] you know that [ __ ]
they used for like a classroom josh
[ __ ] yeah he's like dropped in cement
we're gonna get one of those yeah and
you know it's gonna be like a after
school program where regular kids come
by mm-hmm we teach them how to dance
yeah but the dance instructor is is mad
regular instant sublease yeah yeah there
it is
yeah yeah hmm that's just kind of like
Mad Decent which is cool mm-hmm who the
[ __ ] is that is Nate here yeah here's
the boys here what app I'm really stuck
on this we we have to do this and then
we teach them how to dance to teach them
how to sing yeah and they do dry house
he'd be doing real regular singing loser
house
not no see that's your giving in no no
but I'm saying we but then we make loser
a cool like you want to be it's like Mad
Decent you want to be a loser okay all
right all right
see we flip it all right what the
perspective the alehouse the alehouse
that's so funny
what no can't say it
really can't say it no no no I think I
know what it is but yeah I think I know
exactly what it is oh that's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] no um yeah the alehouse yeah and
they just sell houses be all ELLs in
their regular else just people
comfortable with taking owls yeah yeah
exactly
no it's like you gotta take else yeah to
get the dub use yeah you put a couple
ELLs together
yeah what is that yes a dub that's a dub
yeah yeah that mean that is two L's make
a dub two L's make a dub and you know
that's the that's the slogan that's the
violent yeah
mmm
hey now you know I'll star get your game
on go they're doing like the Macarena
that's shitty songs go play cha-cha
slide singing it themselves the worst
song [ __ ] dude
cha cha slide yeah hard as hell it's
like five six seven eight one two let's
top right to the right to the left slide
to the right crisscross it'll feel like
some [ __ ] fever dream [ __ ] yeah oh my
god this is so funny yeah they're all
using songs that everybody hates songs
that are clearly just so over
yeah like Smash Mouth [ __ ] or whatever
doing dances just shitty white wedding
[Laughter]
they'll that'd be [ __ ] hilarious the
alehouse man we gotta make it two out
cuz two L's make it dub because two L's
make it dad no you know we make it the L
house for real everyone is 27 yeah yeah
yeah no that is one didn't you bring
that up before yeah there's some click
house or some [ __ ] where it's like all
yeah all right no it's what it is just
like dan Bilzerian girls are trying to
make their own it's like yeah it's like
this like clique chicks or something
like that yeah but that doesn't count
dude they're not regular yeah I mean
yeah they all got like big fake tits
what I'm talking about as we get like
you know like a 27 year old like
assistant Account Manager at [ __ ]
Chase Bank you know yeah and at 6
o'clock he pulls up to the alehouse and
he's and he just can't quite keep up
with the choreography yeah yeah I like
that and all the choreo has to be dated
as [ __ ] yeah dated yeah like they're
doing the dougie mmm then NSYNC [ __ ]
yeah it's like a weird it's a horrible
mashup
do the bye-bye-bye into the dougie and
you're like [ __ ] was that
that's how every cliff has to feel what
the [ __ ] was that
asked him we gotta make the antithesis
all this [ __ ] corporates like
smoothed out [ __ ] we got to make the
[ __ ] like the the the chalky tasting
aspect of the internet that's all the
whole thing is to come my baby come come
my baby you my butterfly sugar baby come
my baby my baby start C walk into that
song hey little mama
dancing me Oh going on stop it
then he goes into a head spin Oh goddamn
it
yeah
you